Hello.
Welcome to this video slash livestream depending on
when you're watching.
Where we are gonna take a look at
building our own WebAssembly cloud using the Fermion
platform.
So first, welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although I go
by the handle Rawkode across the Internet.
This course is kindly sponsored by Fermion.
Spin is a really cool framework for writing
microservices
and fill application composed of microservices
using WebAssembly technologies.
And Fermion are at the forefront of that
and this is gonna be fun.
So in order to get started,
we'll pop up my screen share. And I
wanna set just a small
little bit of context
into
Fermion cloud.
And then we'll look at hosting our own.
So I've kind of prepared a very simple
spin application.
And in fact, when I say prepared, I
used spend new to generate the template that
gives us a hello world application.
Let me bump that font size up because
I was coding earlier, which is quite smaller,
which is print hello world.
I've already ran, spend build,
but we can do it one more time.
And we can use spend deploy
to push this to Fermion cloud, which for
now is free.
So you get to deploy up to five
applications on Fermion cloud, kick the tires on
it, doesn't cost you a single penny.
Now because this is already deployed,
we don't really need to wait for this.
Instead, I can just come back to here
and I can see that the app the
URL for this demo application
gives us an internal server,
which is probably because I just redeployed it.
But if we refresh it, we get hello
fermion.
And that's it.
Spend you
Rust code or JavaScript code, maybe some go
code, maybe some dot net, maybe some Python.
You know what? With web assembly, doesn't matter.
Right? In a language that you enjoy writing
in.
We build it, we deploy it, all good.
But what if we want to run it
ourselves?
And this is where I think fermion
gets really interesting.
Is that nothing fermion are doing is closed
source, Everything is available and they open.
And in fact, even Fermion Cloud is just
a collection of components, which are also open
source.
And you can go to github.com/fermion/installer,
where you will find Terraform automation to run
your own little fermion cloud on Amazon,
Azure,
Civo,
Digital Ocean, GCP,
and come in soon, and you'll see the
demo on Tuesday,
Equinix Medal.
Because well, I wanted to do some hacking
and I've got a cool demo for you
next week.
So we're
gonna take this automation and
I'm gonna use the newest one,
which I know is a bit risky, but,
you know, Siam who we all know in
the cloud data space,
who also works for SIVO, put together the
Terraform to deploy the Fermion platform to SIVO
Cloud.
So I have this cloned locally and you'll
see that I'm inside the civil directory which
has a read me
if you really want to read it. Or
you can just do what I like to
do, Which is go straight into the Terraform
directory
and run Terraform edit.
This will pull down all the Terraform plugins
that we need to do this deployment.
I have already exported my SIBO token
and to this environment
hopefully.
So I should be able to run terraform
apply,
which is going to spin up a instance.
We can just quickly run through some of
this.
Yep.
We shall spin up a firewall first
allowing some ports pretty
everything's pretty available. I don't look at it.
A stable instance, which we have some custom
user data, which we may or may not
go through. And then we have the IP
assignment, the network, the reserved IP and SSH
key pair around the password blah blah blah
blah.
Pretty much for a position where we just
wanna hit yes and say go.
So while this spends up because it will
take probably around one to two minutes,
We'll take a look at that automation.
Probably
should pop this open.
Watch approval. Thank you.
And actually, we need a few directories up.
So let's do a code.
Now
each of these implementations for AWS,
GCP, Digital Ocean, etcetera, really just handle the
provisioning of the the instance, the network, the
firewalls, and then also use the data
is provided at this top level directory
called share and then Terraform.
We have a VM assets folder, which the
file provisioner will actually just SCP onto the
machine for you,
which contains a bunch of nomad jobs.
But before it gets to that, it runs
the startup script.
No, I guess now is a good time
to understand which components make up the fermion
cloud or fermion platform.
One, there's HEPL from Dezlabs.
Dezlabs.
Thanks, Hugh.
This is a project for running web assembly.
It's open source. It's still actively maintained. It's
being worked on as experimental warning, but of
course all the best projects do. Right?
So you can run HEPL and
you can ask it to run WebAssembly binaries
for you.
Another part of the platform is Bundle also
by Daislabs.
And Bundle
is an object store for WebAssembly modules.
Now will we still be using Bundle in
three months, six months, nine months? I'm not
entirely sure.
Why? Well, go check out the Spin watch
new 0.8 video that I released last week.
Fermion
have added support for OCI registry for WebAssembly
and Spin applications.
So you can now just do a spin
OCI push
and your spin application will be available via
gapp container registry, docker registry,
Google container registry and so forth.
So where is Bendel in this? I'm not
sure.
It may be that it takes a backseat
for something that is more generic and
something that we're already using for our container
applications.
This opens up a really cool potential for
having our WASM and our container Linux based
applications running side by side.
The bundle and HEPL make up the main
chunk of what we need to build a
WebAssembly platform.
However, we still need to schedule these workloads.
Now there is some really cool work happening
to run
web assembly binaries on container D.
And I'm not gonna talk about it right
now or show you anything with regards to
that because it's early and it's not how
Fermion platform works right now or maybe ever
to be honest. I'm not entirely sure.
But it uses Nomad.
A Nomad is a HashiCorp project
that doesn't have this assumption about the workloads
that's going to schedule an orchestrate
that works really well for WebAssembly binaries and
in fact an interview I did with the
CTO of Fermion was talking about how they
were able to reduce
the
amount of code that they wrote to make
web assembly and Crestlet work within like the
hundreds of thousands of lines of code
but the web assembly support for Nomad was
dozens to hundreds of lanes of code.
Much
easier to reason about and work with.
It's not just Nomad that is console issues
for service discovery and
for making sure the URLs work to browse
to it because traffic sits in the front
as a proxy, speaks to console as a
discovery mechanism for all the web assembly applications
that are available,
sets up all the routing for you and
any secrets that are required come from vault.
So essentially this is a full hashi stack
with a little bit of glue on the
top to make it work for web assembly.
Okay.
Let's see where we are with our deployment.
If you have any questions,
feel free to drop them into the comment
section.
So I just realized I don't even have
open.
Where are my comments?
Let's turn off.
No. It's not hiding up there.
When was the last time I streamed?
Nope. No comment, man.
Where are you?
But he's behind here.
I'm not gonna look for any longer because
I'm just gonna look silly. I
have no idea where that went. Okay, let's
check where we are.
Okay. Cool. So the TerraForm has completed.
We know that because we have all of
the outputs. So we have the bundle address,
which we'll need in just a moment for
pushing our spin application to.
We have a generated SSH key, which will
allow us to get onto the machine.
We have
the DNS host. So by default,
if you don't provide a DNS name, it
uses a slip,
which is really just you put an IP
address on as a the prefix, the sub
the sub domains of the main domain and
it resolves for you. There are loads of
services like this these days. SLEP is just
the one that is used as part of
this automation.
We have a Hippo admin username and password
which we can use to actually browse the
Hippo instance.
Why don't we start there?
Why don't we copy this
and what should happen is when we open
this as we get our own little money
UI
for Fermion Cloud.
Isn't
that neat?
So we could put in that our password
is admin.
We could pop back over here and we
could do terraform
output
JSON
j q dot
hippo
admin
password
dot value.
And this gives us our password.
And now
we can log in.
We don't have any applications. We haven't deployed
anything yet, but you know, this is very
similar to just bare me on cloud.
Next, what do we need to do? Well,
we need to push the application.
So we can just spin login
with a URL parameter.
And this actually oh, that's still the password.
This takes the Hippo URL.
So we can do HEPL.212.24417slip.io.
From here we can see whether everyone to
log in with GitHub or whether username and
password. We do not have any configuration
clients set up for GitHub.
So we're just going to use the same
username and password that we use to get
into the UI.
And next we need to bundle URL,
which is the same as the HEPL URL
only with bundle instead of HEPL.
So we can just do a slip dot
IO and that's where we'll need a slash
v one on the end.
And bundle will be running publicly and unauthenticated.
So if you are going to play around
with running your own web assembly platform,
just remember that it's not secure by default
and
there are plenty of warnings and the read
me to say the same thing too.
Now
we can do is spin deploy.
And because we're authenticated against this new Hippo
server,
it's gonna push it to there.
I logged us in the wrong place.
So we could do a CD
demo
spin
deploy.
We could just give us a few seconds,
but what's gonna happen
is we'll be able to refresh this. In
fact, we can already see it here.
We see that we have our demo application
here.
Now we can get logs,
we can set environment variables,
We can tweak some settings although that aren't
really at this point in time and we
can see that it's still publishing. So it's
actually not going to be available on this
URL just yet.
We pop back to the CLI. Looks like
it's finished. We have a link. It's the
same one as here and I'll open this
in a split
and we can see we have hello fermion.
So most of that was just me waffle
chatting away,
terraform and terraform apply and we have a
web assembly client.
That's pretty much it.
Have our logs there's not really anything there
right now because we don't have any logging
in the default application.
If we want to add an environment variable,
we could say name equals David. We could
click save
and this becomes available to our application.
So you can kinda just do whatever you
want from this point forward.
I am just gonna point out one or
two more things before we wrap up the
session.
You already know the bundle is running on
this machine and it is available publicly,
but so is console.
Well, let's click on the link for that.
You know what? I think it's just available
on the IP address. So let's try.
No.
Alright.
Let's get on this machine.
So we need terraform
output
dash JSON
back at directory terraform
dash
JSON
and we want to grab
the private key,
which is civo private key.
We can j q this only this time
we want a raw value that just means
without quotes.
We want the value of this which is
our key
and we'll write this to
print.
Now because SSH can be a bit funny,
we'll check modus to be print.
I'm gonna do a BSH which is just
an alias that removes host key checking.
Really handy for ephemeral instances where you don't
actually care.
We wanna grab the IP address
here.
And lastly, we wanna specify
a private key.
And we're in.
We're now on the machine where the Fairmount
platform is deployed.
So we can run nomad status, which will
show us that we have our application that
we deployed. That's the UUID that's sitting there.
We have Bundle, we have Heppel and we
have traffic.
Now if you're not familiar with cloud computing
and cloud and how all this works is
when we push the user data to this
machine,
it's pretty standard that you're going to find
the logs
and bar log cloud in it output dot
log.
From here
you'll get to a public IP address
for the console,
the nomad,
the vault. So some of these are private
which means you probably need to set up
an SSH tunnel
but I'm gonna try the IP address on
just to see if it works.
It does. Cool. I worked on my Equinix
mental test. I'm glad it worked on my
SQL test. Yeah. So this is public too.
So just caveat be aware. This could be
a bad thing. Hey, I sent my comments.
There we go.
Hey, Shupam.
Thanks for joining.
Hector JS. Thanks for joining.
So console is here and from here, you
can actually see all of the workloads that
are running too. So you can see
that we have console bundle, hippo, etcetera.
If you do need to debug this at
any point,
you can kind of get in and take
a look and see everything as you can.
But just a word of warning is public.
Please do not use the installer for any
production based stuff.
You're really gonna have to tie down those
firewall rules and make sure that nothing.
This is dangerous and it shouldn't be made
available.
And that's the that's our demo for today.
So we'll check out the Fairmount installer,
run your own web assembly platform on any
major cloud provider that is supported. If there's
a cloud provider that you want to support,
the repo is open source. Please feel free
to open a pull request. Just need to
write a little bit of Terraform.
The great part is all the user data
is
global. It works on all of these providers
provided to use the right version of the
Bintu. So as far as the Terraform contribution
goes, you only really need to spin up
an instance on the cloud with some firewall
rules and it just works.
So go check it out.
I'll be back on Tuesday. We'll be doing
that the Equinix metal demo which I've been
working on. This is going to be a
show us how we can run multiple
fermion platforms
and multiple locations
and use my favorite web technology or at
least networking technology
BGP
that is dynamic written based on where you
are in the world for super low latency
web assembly workloads.
So until then, thank you for joining me.
Have a wonderful day and we'll be back
again soon with more spin videos as part
of the complete spin,
the complete
guide to spin course.
Have a great weekend. I'll see you all
soon.